[Musik]
hallo hallo thomas schön dich zu sehen
wie war der urlaub bestimmt total
günstiger wir werden bald sehr groß otto
größer als jede andere zeitung in der
stadt
soziale netzwerke digitale version apps
und wir sind dabei und für dich ist es
dann auch besser dann lesen mehr frauen
deine anzeigen ich habe eine bitte
thomas ich weiß wie wir zu diesmal
heißen
rodrigo
das ist es nicht wie soll ich dich in
deiner nächsten kontaktanzeige
beschreiben der einfühlsamsten mann der
welt sucht seine erfüllung total
verständnisvoller charmanter als alle
anderen männer oder lieber ein bisschen
direkter der mann vor dem sie ihre
kinder waren aber von denen sie ganz
heimlich träumen
thomas ich möchte keine kontaktanzeige
mir was ich habe mich total verliebt
thomas und zwar recht
sie ist die tollste lustigste frau die
ich in meinem leben kennengelernt habe
und ich möchte dass du mir hilft sie nie
mehr zu verlieren
wir kennen uns jetzt seit 15 jahren
ordnung
seit zehn jahren schalte ich
kontaktanzeigen in meiner zeitung für
dich den gefallen durch der sehr gerne
mein freund